it was recommended to me a couple of
weeks ago that I should do a video on
how to respond to about grading exam or
more broadly failure in academia and I
think this is a very important subject
and it is worth a video on its site and
even if it's just a quick one because a
lot of people will go for years in
academia in how a string of successes
and - no wrong whatsoever and all it
takes is one bad grade or one bad set of
exams and it can be curtains it can
finish off their academic careers no one
wants that fragility to their academic
career so even if you've never had a
serious set of academic failures I think
it's worth watching this video now some
people might look at my channel and say
well you went to Oxford you clearly did
very well in all your exams what on
earth can you say about failure academic
baby well I've had my fair share of
academic failure and I'm going to talk a
little bit about that later in the video
my point is that I have achieved the
things like achieve in academia
not necessarily despite failures but in
a way because of them because my opinion
is that you can view a bad grade a bad
series of exams in one of two ways and
this actually doesn't just apply to
academia this applies to anything in
life like my breakup or not doing well
in a sports match you can view these bad
events in one of two ways and this is
informed incidentally by reading most
notably a book called mindset by Carol
Dweck you can view bad events in one of
two ways
either you can view something bad
happening like a bad grade as being
purely reflective on your worth as a
person if I get a bad grade in an exam
that indicates to me that I am not smart
enough to do well that I am not as
clever as those people who got A's and a
stars in a more broader sense if this
was sports or music it would indicate
that I am not as good at football or
rugby or playing the clarinet or the
piano as the person who do better than
me fundamentally I am NOT
as good at X than this person was if you
choose to view bad events in this way
then you can kind of see why people go
off the rails from that point onwards
because you might say to yourself well
if I'm not good enough to get a good
grade why am I even bothering you know
I'm clearly just stupid I'm not good
enough I'm not going to try and often
people who have this mindset will do
exactly that in tests they have been
shown to once they've been given a
difficult problem and have received a
bad mark whatever it may be in that
problem that point onwards their level
of effort decreases their attainment
correspondingly decreases the second way
of viewing a bad mark is as follows it
doesn't represent who you are as a
person it doesn't tell you anything
about you fundamentally what it is
instead is an opportunity to improve a
difficult math problem shouldn't
necessarily be oh I can't do this I'm
not good enough I'm just stupid instead
it should be this is an opportunity for
me to improve if I can do this problem
that's going to make me smarter equally
if you were to say fail music exam it
will tell you not I'm just not good at
playing the piano instead it should tell
you that if I can pass this exam it's an
opportunity to improve it's an
opportunity to make myself better at
playing the piano and so it is with a
bad grade if you receive a C or a D in a
subject that shouldn't say to you I'm
just not good at it it should say T this
is an opportunity to improve I can make
myself better at this subject and again
in tests people who have this mindset of
bad effects improve over time and it's
actually surprising to have documented
it all it takes is a mindset of
improvement it takes the ability to look
at a bad situation and go you know what
this doesn't mean anything like me as a
person what it is is a chance to improve
it's an opportunity to improve myself to
return to a point I made earlier about
me people might not think that I know
nothing of academic failure
well something which I've never
mentioned before is that I failed my
first year Oxford
she point out I wasn't alone in doing
this it was quite a widely failed set of
exams by a lot of people but all the
same I didn't exactly do well I'm really
looking back on it I had two options I
could either view that failure and and
time at the fact that I came into Oxford
thinking I don't think I'm as good as
these other people and I'm assuming them
at the very bottom of the Year at time
out in with failing the year I could
have very easily just thought you know
what I'm not good enough for this I'm
just going to drop out I can't do this
but although it didn't consciously
realize at the time what I thought was
no you know what I'm going to work
harder I'm going to improve myself I'm
going to show these people that I can
take these exams that I can do physics
so much better than I could before and I
did I took my resuts and almost got a
first on average I was a half a percent
off a first on average it's not
necessarily the easiest thing to do but
you have to sometimes look at failure in
the face and say I'm not going to let
this define me I am going to learn from
this I'm going to use this to improve
myself if you keep with that mindset and
if you keep trying keep applying effort
in the right way failure won't define
you success will please comment if you
found this video useful by the way and
also if you have any stories of your own
of times when you've overcome academic
setbacks and come back stronger from the
experience or in sport or music or
really anything in life please leave
those in the comments below cuz I'd be
really interested to see how my
subscribers have come to terms with not
necessarily doing as well as they might
like and also share your story inspire
others